let's go to our next caller from the
nine one eight area code caller from
nine one eight who's this where you're
calling from my name is Raquel I'm
calling from Tulsa Oklahoma
all right Raquel what's on your mind
today well my husband and I have been
fighting an immigration battle for the
last five years
we got an i-130 visa he's from Yemen
originally yeah and we have just had so
many problems one day they'll say okay
everything looks good and then the next
moment they'll come up with some excuse
why to extend it and put in
administrative processing and sorry yes
this is which which agency is this this
is USCIS okay United States Immigration
Services Center and what's an example of
the stuff we're like what would be an
example of something that they say needs
to be done after saying it looks like
everything's go first they made up this
theory about polygamy polygamy and we
were able to prove that there was no
polygamy okay and that was well that was
that was a lot of fun Raquel if we can
if we can talk through it so there was a
question raised about whether your
husband in Yemen was involved in a
polygamist situation that is correct
that is correct but what happened was he
left Yemen and he went to Norway right
okay and he's been in Norway for the
past ten years right okay so I left
Norway because it's a very expensive
country sure to live in all right we've
been trying to get him over to the
United States as has been going on for
five years and we've had nothing but
problems so this isn't you know
necessarily related sorry Raquel this
isn't necessarily even related to Trump
that this has been going on even before
Trump yeah this but it does relate back
to Trump because he wants to do a ban on
five different countries and Yemen is
involved right but I guess what I'm
saying is there were three years before
Trump during which you also were happy
absolutely yes got it got it but now the
betting has came so extreme I can't even
get my husband into this country neither
one of us committed a crime sure neither
one of us have done anything to deserve
what has happened so to be clear Raquel
because you're married he will
eventually he should eventually be
allowed to join you and would qualify
for citizenship through marriage right
like it's it's being delayed yeah okay
yes this is a problem now that they've
made it where you have to go out and get
an attorney whether you can afford one
or not and it just became a very
expensive process so I don't know what
to say I just I think once he's out of
power and we get somebody in somebody
else different I think we'll have a
better chance of getting him in through
this country that maybe although the
fact that it was so difficult even under
Obama certainly makes me slightly
skeptical of that but I think it will be
better it just could be six years Raquel
I got to run I appreciate hearing from
I'm really sorry for what's going on it
sounds it sounds really really bad and
it sounds partially related to to Donald
Trump that's all the time I have for
calls today we will take calls again if
you're holding and there are many of you
I apologize we didn't get to you but we
are just out of time we will take calls
next week quick break back after this